so i want you to think back when you had
to write your first paper
do you remember what typeface you used
this is my old college english paper and
guess what it's written in times new
roman
this is the mueller report a government
document
president trump says he's [ __ ] in it
it is also written
in times new roman times new roman is
the default typeface for everything we
see
from term papers and congress to movie
posters and books
but why is times new roman the default
typeface
the way we think about typefaces today
was not how it has always been
movable type goes back to 1040ad in
china but the first repeated typefaces
for the masses was this
created in the 1450s by johannes
gutenberg in maine's germany between
1450 and 1455
they're not exactly sure when the first
gutenberg bible was released to the
public
this movable type was the first typeface
that could be duplicated many times
printed by way of the printing press a
device used to duplicate things many
times the same every time
revolutionary during this period and the
first typefaces were meant to look
hand-drawn to imitate the scribes
when the printing press came out it
involved physically cutting each letter
to be set into a block to show each word
line and page allowing itself to be
duplicated the same way
every time before scribes or people who
would just copy the text
would have to rewrite text by hand a
long and expensive process
now today typefaces and unlimited fonts
are just a click away
[Music]
times new roman was a typeface born out
of anger it all started with this man
stanley morrison
morrison was a freelance consultant for
a famous newspaper in london
the times london the newspaper at the
time was using a typeface that mr
morrison did not like
mr morrison wrote an article in the
times london newspaper itself
talking about how he disliked the
typeface that the newspaper was
currently using
he thought the typeface did not match
the characteristics of the paper itself
the old typeface according to mr
morrison was hard to read and did not
look professional he became upset
because of how the newspaper physically
looked
after the article came out the london
times owner took mr morrison up on his
offer
and commissioned him to create a
typeface for the newspaper mr morrison
began to work with the typesetter who
had physically cut the pieces for him mr
morrison and his typesetter used
plantain as a base to start designing
time's new roman around
they knew that the typeface had to be
easy to read it also had to fit more
words on a page so it was more
economical
there's only so much room on a newspaper
this is stephen heller he's written a
plethora of books on design and he's an
expert in this field
and times roman was based on
the idea that their would be so many
words to a column
newspapers you know were not
generous about white space so they
needed to get as much packed in as
possible
does its job well as one of those
kind of crystal goblet type faces it's
seen but not heard they designed times
new roman as a solution
times new roman is a narrower typeface
it has small spaces between each letter
which is contrasted by wide portions of
the letter themselves
allowing them to stand out in print at
the end of the day
times new roman is a typeface designed
to be read on paper that is why it was
created and that is what it does best
the united states government used to use
the typeface courier
which is a shorter font it also has less
contrast between the letters themselves
making it harder to read
and if you're about to read something
from the us government it helps if it's
easy to read
mr heller says typefaces are like
speaking with an accent
designers that's their language
so you know if you were talking to me
with a certain accent let's say i
might respond negatively to it
you know there are certain accents like
you know you watch a
war movie on tv and the german accent
is always grading although i kind of
like it
but that's what type is it it
it itself is a voice presents the words
of an idea
uh but the face the style of the face
the serifs
the design of the ascenders and
descenders
these are the accents these are the
visual nuances but at the same time
they're the sound of the typeface
you know you can like it or hate it so
choosing your language in which you
wrote was the first impression you had
on someone
choosing a typeface that was known to
all would make it seem like you could
speak to anyone
[Music]
welcome to the computer chronicles i'm
stuart chaffe and this is gary kildahl
gary i have some examples here of
printed documents
the kinds of things normally you think
you have to go to a printer and pay a
lot of money to get but these were all
created on a personal computer
times new roman is economical it is a
relatively cheap typeface to print out
compared to other typefaces
back in the day when printers started
becoming a thing they were very
expensive
so one had to be economical in their
printing habits can
everyone see this i know the types a
little small
it's if your word processing looks like
word processing and your graphics aren't
too graphic
you need a canon laser printer to make
the printed page look better
for as little as two thousand eight
hundred dollars
since it was so costly for printers
people began looking at what could save
them money when they had to print out
documents
and it's because it was so costly that
even the us government got smart and
changed from their default found of
courier to times new roman in 2004
quote it takes up almost exactly the
same area on the page as courier new 12
while offering a crisper cleaner more
modern look
end quote which is why the mueller
report from the us government is written
in times new roman
in fact all u.s bills are written in
times in roman shown here is a word
count that fits on one page
time zeroman wins against other popular
fonts showing that this typeface can
print out more words for less cost
compared to alternative typefaces
courier and helvetica
so it is more legible than courier and
cheaper to print out than helvetica
it was also right around this time that
more students began writing by computers
than writing by hand or typewriter
there's a lot more interest from
teachers now and they're starting to use
computers within their classroom
and a lot of different students in palo
alto are now starting to use
word processing and some other types of
programs data management kinds of
programs to help them so the
computer computer's becoming more of a
tool for them most computers released
around this time included times new
roman due to its wide licensing deals
with monotype and lana type
licensing is a huge way to get your type
out there if it's not available to the
masses it can't be used
i'm steve jobs from apple computer we're
very glad to be here tonight
now you know that over 70 percent of all
the computers used in education are
apples
and that makes us feel really good and
they're telling us that macintosh is the
ideal college computer so we think
you're going to see lots of macintoshes
on college campuses with mack wright
even though there's a lot of features
they're all very easy to use you can
also however go up and change the style
you see that right there that's a
typeface called new york designed by
susan care in 1983
it's a spitting image of time's new
roman windows version 3.1
and 1991 had times new roman so this was
the first time that you had a wide
selection of typeface choices
which included times new roman and its
twin new york getting in front of users
and getting them used to the typeface
eventually new york would be replaced
with times new roman and it became
widely available on mac and windows
operating systems from then
on out times new roman isn't the
prettiest typeface out there
and it's not the most popular and in
fact most people if ass tend to favor
helvetica over times new roman
but since it's not licensed by google no
one can use helvetica when using google
docs
but if you scroll down past the h's
you'll find the times new roman typeface
looking right at you
this creates a gap in the market people
write with what is legible cheap and
familiar
enter times new roman so because times
new roman was inexpensive to license
cheap to print in bulk and highly
legible it became the default typeface
on most word processing programs like
microsoft word and macroite
so an entire generation grew up using
this typeface
not by choice but because it was the
font given to you to start with and what
everyone came to be used to
so these days times new roman is no
longer the system default
but its impression on culture has made
it an expressive design choice rather
than an economic system default
so the default isn't always the best at
everything but it's usually the one with
the least amount of drama
[Music]
and thank you for watching today's video
i'm obviously a big fan of the vox video
channel
and so when i started this project i
wanted to see if i could do a video like
them
but for our channel so if you like this
share with a friend
it helps convince chris and matt that we
should do more videos like this in the
future
so i just want to thank you for watching
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]
i think that's gonna be the winner